- أهلاً بكم مجدداً في فهم المعلومات
والحوسبة الكمية.
اسمي John Watrous، وأنا المدير التقني
للتعليم في IBM Quantum.
هذا هو الدرس الثاني من السلسلة. إذا لم تشاهدوا
الدرس الأول بعد، تأكدوا من مشاهدته.
سنبني مباشرة على ما تحدثنا عنه
في الدرس الأول، لذا من المهم أن يكون لديكم
فهم لتلك المادة قبل الدخول في هذا الدرس.
كذلك، انتبهوا أن السلسلة
تتضمن محتوى كتاب دراسي بالإضافة إلى الفيديوهات، ويمكنكم إيجاد رابط
لمحتوى الكتاب الدراسي
في وصف الفيديو. هذا الدرس الثاني من
الوحدة الأولى في السلسلة.
الوحدة الأولى تغطي أساسيات
المعلومات الكمية.
في الدرس السابق، تحدثنا عن المعلومات الكمية في سياق الأنظمة المفردة، بمعنى أن لدينا نظاماً واحداً
يخزن المعلومات
ونحن نصف كيف
يعمل بمعزل عن غيره.
قضينا وقتاً لا بأس به في
المعلومات الكلاسيكية، أساساً لتأسيس نقطة مرجعية ولإبراز التشابهات
الرياضية
بين المعلومات الكمية والكلاسيكية.
رأينا أيضاً كيف يمكن تمثيل الحالات الكمية بمتجهات، تحديداً متجهات ذات
مدخلات أعداد مركبة ومعيار إقليدي يساوي واحد،
وناقشنا قياسات الأساس القياسي
والعمليات الأحادية.
في هذا الدرس، سنوسع نظرتنا
لتشمل أنظمة متعددة، كل منها قادر على
تخزين المعلومات الكمية.
هذا ليس مجرد مسألة أن نقول أن كل نظام فردي
يعمل كما ناقشنا المرة الماضية، هناك معنى يكون فيه الكل
أعظم من مجموع الأجزاء، وهذا ينطبق أيضاً على
المعلومات الكلاسيكية عندما تكون الاحتمالات متضمنة.
الأنظمة المتعددة يمكنها
التفاعل مع بعضها البعض ويمكن أن تكون مترابطة
مع بعضها على سبيل المثال، وفي السياق الكمي، يتضمن ذلك إمكانية
أن تكون الأنظمة متشابكة، وهو مصطلح ربما
سمعتم به من قبل.
التشابك ظاهرة
مهمة جداً في المعلومات الكمية وسيكون لدينا الكثير لنقوله عنها مع استمرار السلسلة.
هناك مبدأ بسيط، مع ذلك، يوفر لنا قدراً كبيراً من القدرة على التفكير في
وفهم المعلومات الكمية للأنظمة المتعددة،
وهو أنه يمكننا دائماً
أخذ نظامين أو أكثر ووضعهم معاً أو مجرد التفكير بهم
معاً من الناحية المفاهيمية
والنظر إليهم كأنهم يشكلون
نظاماً مركباً واحداً.
وعندما نفكر في نظام
مركب كهذا، كأنه نظام واحد، ندرك أنه يجب وصفه بطريقة تتوافق
مع كل ما تعلمناه
في الدرس السابق عن الأنظمة المفردة.
سنرى كيف يعمل هذا
وكيف يبرز وصف المعلومات الكمية
من الأنظمة المتعددة بشكل طبيعي جداً من طريقة عملها للأنظمة المفردة
بناءً على هذا المبدأ الواحد. إليكم نظرة عامة على الدرس وهي تصادف أنها مطابقة لنظرة الدرس السابق العامة،
لكن هذه المرة تركيزنا
سيكون على الأنظمة المتعددة بدلاً من الأنظمة المفردة.
تماماً كما فعلنا في الدرس السابق ولنفس الأسباب بالضبط، سنبدأ بالمعلومات
الكلاسيكية.
مرة أخرى، سنرى
تشابهات وثيقة جداً بين طريقة عمل المعلومات الكمية
والكلاسيكية على المستوى الرياضي.
لن نركز عادةً بهذا القدر
على المعلومات الكلاسيكية أو نبدأ كل درس في السلسلة بالمعلومات الكلاسيكية هكذا.
الدروس اللاحقة ستميل للتركيز بشكل أكثر حصرية على المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية.
لكن هنا في البداية
هذا نهج منطقي ويعود إلى فكرة أن التفكير في المعلومات الكلاسيكية
يمكن أن يكون مصدراً قيماً للتوجيه في فهم المعلومات الكمية.
سنناقش أيضاً
المفهوم المهم لحاصل الضرب التنسوري في
هذا الجزء من الدرس.
حواصل الضرب التنسورية مهمة للغاية في المعلومات الكمية، لكنها تظهر أيضاً في
السياق الكلاسيكي.
ثم سننتقل إلى المعلومات الكمية وكما في الدرس السابق سنناقش الحالات الكمية،
قياسات الأساس القياسي،
والعمليات الأحادية هذه
المرة للأنظمة المتعددة.
سنبدأ بالحديث
عن الحالات الكلاسيكية للأنظمة المتعددة.
تذكروا من الدرس
السابق أن الحالة الكلاسيكية للنظام هي
تكوين لذلك النظام يمكن التعرف عليه ووصفه
بشكل لا لبس فيه
بدون أي شك أو خطأ. وبالمصطلحات الرياضية، عندما نشير إلى مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية،
نعني ببساطة مجموعة محدودة وغير فارغة.
سنبدأ مناقشتنا
للأنظمة المتعددة بافتراض أن لدينا
نظامين فقط X وY.
X لديه مجموعة من الحالات الكلاسيكية سنسميها سيجما تماماً
كما في الدرس السابق، وY لديه مجموعة من الحالات الكلاسيكية
سنسميها جاما. المجموعة سيجما وجاما
يمكن أن تكونا نفس المجموعة أو مختلفتين،
لكننا نعطيهما أسماء مختلفة، ليس فقط لأنهما
قد تكونان مجموعتين مختلفتين، ولكن أيضاً لأن ذلك سيساعدنا
على إبقاء الأمور واضحة إذا أعطيناهما أسماء مختلفة.
سنجد أنه من
السهل جداً تعميم هذه المناقشة بأكملها من نظامين إلى أي عدد من الأنظمة، لكن
بالبدء بنظامين،
يمكننا التركيز على الأفكار الأساسية دون الغرق في التفاصيل.
الآن، تخيلوا أننا
وضعنا X وY جنباً إلى جنب مع X على اليسار وY على اليمين، ونرى هذين النظامين معاً
كأنهما يشكلان نظاماً مركباً واحداً.
لإعطاء هذا النظام الجديد اسماً، يمكننا كتابته كزوج
مرتب هكذا، أو يمكننا ببساطة وضع
الحرفين بجانب بعضهما هكذا.
كلاهما شائع ويمكننا
اختيار أيهما نريد أو أيهما أكثر ملاءمة.
في كلتا الحالتين، سنقرؤها XY.
سؤال طبيعي جداً
نطرحه في هذه المرحلة هو ما هي الحالات الكلاسيكية لهذا النظام المركب الجديد XY؟
والإجابة على هذا السؤال هي أن مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية لـ XY هي الجداء الديكارتي
لمجموعتي الحالات الكلاسيكية،
سيجما وجاما، والتي يمكنكم
رؤية تعريفها هنا.
في لحظة معينة، X لديه حالة كلاسيكية ما
وهي عنصر من سيجما، وY لديه حالة كلاسيكية ما
وهي عنصر من جاما،
ونحن ببساطة نفكر
في هاتين الحالتين معاً كأنهما تشكلان حالة واحدة، وهذا بالضبط المفهوم
الذي يجسده الجداء الديكارتي. لدينا عنصران،
واحد من كل مجموعة من مجموعاتنا، ونريد التفكير في
هذين العنصرين معاً
كأنهما يشكلان عنصراً
واحداً من مجموعة واحدة.
للتوضيح، هناك افتراض هنا وهو أننا نعرف
أي نظام هو X وأيهما Y،
ولا يوجد خلط بينهما. ليس المهم أن X فعلياً على الجانب الأيسر
وY على اليمين،
بل المهم أن النظامين
قابلان للتمييز وأننا قررنا
ترتيبهما بهذه الطريقة فقط حتى نتمكن من
معرفة أيهما أي.
إليكم مثالاً بسيطاً جداً حيث سيجما هي الأبجدية الثنائية وجاما هي المجموعة
التي تحتوي على رموز البطاقات الأربعة.
إذا كان X يخزن قيمة ثنائية وY يخزن أحد رموز البطاقات الأربعة، فهناك ثماني
حالات كلاسيكية ممكنة
للزوج XY، والتي يمكنكم
رؤيتها مدرجة هنا.
لأكثر من نظامين، يُعمم هذا بطريقة مباشرة.
بالتحديد إذا كانت X1 حتى Xn أنظمة لها مجموعات حالات
كلاسيكية سيجما واحد حتى سيجما n على التوالي.
فإذا تخيلنا تجميع
الأنظمة الـ n معاً والنظر إليها كنظام واحد، فإن مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية تُعطى
بالجداء الديكارتي
لمجموعات الحالات الكلاسيكية الـ n
سيجما واحد حتى سيجما n.
كما ترون هنا على الشاشة. الجداء الديكارتي
يمكن تعريفه هكذا لأي عدد من المجموعات.
على سبيل المثال، إذا كان لدينا ثلاثة أنظمة وكلها تشترك في الأبجدية الثنائية كمجموعة حالاتها الكلاسيكية، أي بعبارة أخرى لدينا ثلاث بتات،
فهناك ثماني
حالات كلاسيكية ممكنة للبتات الثلاث عند النظر إليها
معاً كنظام واحد ويمكنكم رؤيتها مدرجة هنا.
كل نظام بمفرده يمكن
أن يكون في الحالة صفر أو واحد، ونمر على جميع
التوليفات الممكنة.
يمكن كتابة الصف n من الحالات الكلاسيكية بشكل بديل كسلسلة حيث نحذف
الأقواس والفواصل كما ترون هنا.
وهذا منطقي بشكل خاص عندما نفكر في
الحالات الكلاسيكية كرموز كما في المثال الشائع جداً
للأبجدية الثنائية
الذي نعود إليه باستمرار. أحياناً يكون من المريح جداً فعل هذا ويميل إلى جعل
تعبيراتنا أبسط
وأقل ازدحاماً. مفهوم السلسلة في الواقع يُصاغ رسمياً
بالمصطلحات الرياضية من خلال الجداءات الديكارتية،
لذا هذا في الحقيقة مجرد
ترميز بديل وليس شيئاً مختلفاً مفاهيمياً.
كمثال، لنقل أن لدينا
10 بتات X1 حتى X10.
هذا يعني أن مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية للبتات العشر معاً،
والتي قد تفكرون فيها بشكل طبيعي كسجل 10 بت
في حاسوب مثلاً،
هي الجداء الديكارتي عشري الطيات
للأبجدية الثنائية مع نفسها.
وإذا كتبنا تلك الحالات كسلاسل، تبدو كما ترون
هنا، هناك 1,024 منها،
لذا بالطبع ليست كلها مدرجة هنا. هذه النقاط الثلاث هنا
من المفترض أن تشير إلى أن هناك نمطاً يمكنكم استنتاجه
ونأمل أن تكونوا فهمتم الفكرة. الآن هناك اتفاقية
سنتبعها لترتيب عناصر
مجموعات الجداء الديكارتي،
ومن المهم
توضيح هذا من أجل تمثيل كل من الحالات الاحتمالية والحالات الكمية كمتجهات.
الاتفاقية هي أننا
نرتب عناصر مجموعات الجداء الديكارتي
ترتيباً معجمياً، وهو ما يعني أساساً
الترتيب القاموسي.
لنكون أكثر تحديداً، نبدأ بافتراض أن كل مجموعة من المجموعات الفردية التي نأخذ الجداء الديكارتي لها لديها ترتيبها الخاص بالفعل
ونفكر في صف n معين
أو سلسلة كأنها كلمة ونرتبها
أبجدياً.
طريقة أخرى لقول هذا هي أن المواقع داخل
صف n أو سلسلة تتناقص في الأهمية
من اليسار إلى اليمين،
تماماً كما نكتب الأرقام باستخدام الخانات من صفر إلى تسعة.
إليكم مثالاً يهدف
لتوضيح هذا.
إذا أخذنا الجداء الديكارتي بين المجموعات التي تحتوي على
واحد واثنين وثلاثة والأبجدية الثنائية، نحصل على مجموعة تحتوي ستة عناصر
وهنا مدرجة بالترتيب
الذي يتم وصفه.
كل العناصر التي فيها
واحد في الموقع الأول تأتي قبل كل العناصر التي فيها اثنان في الموقع الأول وهي تأتي قبل كل العناصر
التي فيها ثلاثة في الموقع الأول. وعندما يتفق عنصران
في الموقع الأول، نرجع إلى الترتيب
في الموقع الثاني.
إذن هذا هو الترتيب الذي
نستخدمه للجداءات الديكارتية.
لاحظوا أنه عندما نستخدم هذه الاتفاقية ونكتب صفوف n كسلاسل، نلاحظ بعض الأنماط المألوفة جداً.
على سبيل المثال، الجداء الديكارتي للأبجدية
الثنائية مع نفسها يُرتب كما ترون هنا،
ويمكنكم التفكير في هذه السلاسل على أنها مرتبة عددياً إذا اعتبرتم هذه السلاسل
كترميزات ثنائية لأعداد صحيحة غير سالبة
وهذا يُعمم
لأي طول سلسلة. بالانتقال إلى الحالات الاحتمالية، نعلم بالفعل من الدرس السابق
أن الحالة الاحتمالية تربط احتمالاً بكل حالة
كلاسيكية لنظام معين.
إذا كان لدينا نظام مركب حيث أخذنا نظامين أو أكثر ونرى مجموعهم كأنهم يشكلون نظاماً
واحداً كما ناقشنا للتو،
فإن الحالة الاحتمالية
لهذا النظام المركب يجب أن تعين احتمالات لعناصر الجداء الديكارتي
للأنظمة الفردية،
مجموعات الحالات الكلاسيكية. ذلك لأن هذه هي
مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية للنظام المركب.
على سبيل المثال، بافتراض
أن X وY بتات، لدينا هذا المثال على
حالة احتمالية لـ XY.
احتمال أن تكون كلتا
البتتين صفراً هو نصف واحتمال أن تكون كلتا
البتتين واحداً هو نصف، وبالتالي البتتان لا تختلفان أبداً.
إنها حالة احتمالية صالحة لـ XY، ويمكننا بشكل بديل
كتابتها كمتجه
كما ترون هنا وهنا يمكنكم رؤية أننا
نتبع الاتفاقية التي وصفتها قبل قليل لترتيب هذه الحالات الكلاسيكية.
هذا مثال على
حالة احتمالية حيث X وY مترابطان، وهذا هو المعنى الذي يكون فيه الكل
أعظم من مجموع الأجزاء. كما اقترحت سابقاً، الأمر ليس ببساطة أن
لدينا حالة احتمالية
لـ X وحالة احتمالية لـ Y ونجمعهما معاً، بل نجمع
الأنظمة أولاً
ثم نفكر في
الحالات الاحتمالية للنظام المركب.
لنكون أكثر دقة بشأن
الترابطات بين الأنظمة. نبدأ بتعريف
مفهوم الاستقلال، الذي هو أساساً
غياب الترابط.
هنا بالمناسبة، مصطلح الاستقلال يشير
إلى الاستقلال الإحصائي بدلاً من الاستقلال الخطي
للمتجهات مثلاً.
إنه مفهوم أساسي في
الاحتمالات والإحصاء.
إذا كان لدينا نظامان X وY ولدينا حالة احتمالية
ما لـ XY في ذهننا، فنقول أن X وY مستقلان.
إذا كانت الصيغة التي
ترونها هنا صحيحة لكل اختيار للحالات
الكلاسيكية a وb لـ X وY.
إحدى طرق تفسير شرط
الاستقلال هذا هي أنه يقول أن احتمال أن يكون X في أي حالة كلاسيكية
واحتمال أن يكون Y في حالة كلاسيكية أخرى ليس لهما أي علاقة
ببعضهما البعض على الإطلاق.
إذن، معرفة حالة
أحد الأنظمة لا تؤثر على
الاحتمالات المرتبطة بحالات النظام الآخر.
إذا تخيلتم اختيار
حالة كلاسيكية لـ X بشكل عشوائي وفق إجراء ما ثم اختيار
حالة كلاسيكية لـ Y بشكل عشوائي
وفق إجراء آخر ليس مرتبطاً بأي شكل
بإجراء X، كأن يقلب شخص عملة معدنية
وشخص آخر في
غرفة مختلفة يرمي نرداً، فهذه هي الصيغة
التي ستستخدمونها لحساب الاحتمالات
لتوليفات مختلفة
من الحالات التي تظهر. الهدف من التعريف هو أن الاستقلال يكون
عندما تكون الصيغة صالحة.
عندما نفكر في الحالات الاحتمالية من حيث متجهات الاحتمال، هناك صياغة بسيطة
لهذا الشرط
تحديداً إذا كان لدينا
حالة احتمالية لـ XY، والتي يمكننا التعبير عنها كمتجه
بترميز ديراك
كما ترون هنا. فإن القول بأن X وY مستقلان يكافئ وجود
متجهي احتمال،
كِت Phi وكِت Psi والتي بالمناسبة يمكننا ببساطة
قراءتها كـ Phi وPsi اختصاراً وتمثل
حالات احتمالية لـ X وY بشكل منفصل تحقق هذه المساواة
التي ترونها هنا.
لجميع اختيارات a وb، هي أساساً
إعادة صياغة للتعريف بلغة المتجهات.
على سبيل المثال، إليكم حالة احتمالية
لزوج من البتات XY حيث X وY مستقلان.
الشرط المطلوب
للاستقلال صحيح للمتجهات
التي ترونها هنا.
أي أن احتمال
كل إعداد ممكن للبتتين يُعطى بحاصل ضرب الاحتمالات المقابلة
للبتات الفردية.
على سبيل المثال، احتمال أن تأخذ كلتا
البتتين القيمة صفر يساوي سُدس، وهو يساوي ربع
ضرب ثلثين،
وكذلك بالنسبة للاحتمالات
الثلاثة الأخرى التي يمكن التحقق منها واحدة تلو الأخرى.
بالنسبة للحالة الاحتمالية التي رأيناها سابقاً من ناحية أخرى حيث
لدينا بتتان تتفقان دائماً وتأخذان القيمتين صفر و
واحد باحتمال نصف
ليس لدينا استقلال ولهذا نقول أن
البتات مترابطة.
الترابط يعني ببساطة
غياب الاستقلال.
طريقة بسيطة للبرهنة على أن
البتتين ليستا مستقلتين هي افتراض أنهما كذلك واستنتاج تناقض
تحديداً إذا كانت البتتان
مستقلتين، يجب أن توجد
أرقام q0 وq1 وr0 وr1
تمثل احتمالات
للبتتين الفرديتين بحيث تتحقق هذه المعادلات
هنا.
هذه هي الاحتمالات
التي تأتي من متجهنا وهذه هي
المعادلات التي يجب أن تكون صحيحة بموجب شرط الاستقلال،
لكن إذا نظرنا إلى هذه
المساواة الثانية هنا، نرى أنها تتطلب أن
q0 ضرب r1 يساوي صفراً،
لكن الطريقة الوحيدة التي يمكن
أن يكون فيها حاصل ضرب عددين حقيقيين مساوياً للصفر هي إذا كان أحد هذين
العددين على الأقل نفسه يساوي صفراً.
هذا يُسمى أحياناً
خاصية حاصل الضرب الصفري للأعداد الحقيقية.
طريقة أخرى لقول ذلك هي أن حاصل ضرب عددين حقيقيين غير
صفريين يكون دائماً غير صفري.
إذن هذه المساواة
هنا تعني أن إما q0 يساوي صفراً أو r1 يساوي صفراً،
لكن من المساواة الأولى والأخيرة نرى أن أياً من
هذين البديلين لا يمكن أن يكون صحيحاً.
إذا كان q0 يساوي صفراً، فإن هذا الحاصل يجب أن يساوي صفراً، لكنه لا يساوي صفراً
وإذا كان r1 يساوي صفراً،
فإن هذا الحاصل يجب أن يساوي صفراً، لكن هذا ليس صحيحاً أيضاً.
إذن لدينا تناقض
ونستنتج أن X وY ليسا مستقلين وبالتالي هما مترابطان.
مفهوم الاستقلال
الذي ناقشناه للتو وتحديداً صياغته بلغة متجهات
الاحتمال مرتبط ارتباطاً وثيقاً
بعملية يمكن
إجراؤها على المتجهات تُعرف بحاصل الضرب التنسوري.
يمكن تعريف حواصل الضرب التنسورية
ليس فقط للمتجهات بل أيضاً للمصفوفات
وفي الواقع يمكن تعريف مفهوم حاصل الضرب التنسوري
للعديد من أنواع
الكائنات الرياضية الأخرى أيضاً.
يمكن وصفها
بطريقة مجردة جداً وهي
مهمة ومفيدة في الرياضيات البحتة، لكن يمكننا أيضاً تعريف
حواصل الضرب التنسورية للمتجهات
بطريقة بسيطة وملموسة جداً، وهذا هو المسار الذي
سنسلكه في هذا الدرس.
إذا كان لدينا متجهان عموديان Phi وPsi مكتوبان بالصيغ التي ترونها هنا حيث سيجما وجاما هي أي
اختيار لمجموعات الحالات الكلاسيكية
نريدها أو مؤشرات إن فضلتم، فإن حاصل الضرب التنسوري لهذين المتجهين هو المتجه الذي ترونه هنا.
نمر على جميع عناصر
الجداء الديكارتي للمجموعتين، سيجما وجاما، والمدخلة في هذا
المتجه التي تقابل
كل زوج ab، المكتوب
كسلسلة هنا، تساوي حاصل ضرب
المدخلات المقابلة
في هذين المتجهين. بعبارة أخرى، المدخلة ab لـ Phi تنسور Psi هي حاصل ضرب المدخلة a
لـ Phi والمدخلة b لـ Psi،
وهذا هو معنى
ما هو مكتوب هنا.
في الجوهر، هذه هي نفس العملية التي رأيناها قبل لحظات عندما ناقشنا الاستقلال
والآن نحن فقط نعطيها اسماً.
إليكم نفس المثال بالضبط
الذي رأيناه قبل قليل مكتوباً بشكل أكثر وضوحاً بلغة
حاصل الضرب التنسوري.
مرة أخرى، لدينا أن سُدس يساوي ربع ضرب ثلث، واحد على اثني عشر يساوي ربع
ضرب ثلث وهكذا.
هنا، بالمناسبة، طريقتان
بديلتان لكتابة حاصل الضرب التنسوري
لمتجهين.
عندما نستخدم ترميز ديراك ونكتب كِتَّين بجانب
بعضهما هكذا، فهذا يعني حاصل الضرب التنسوري.
لذا يمكنكم التفكير في حاصل الضرب التنسوري كأنه الطريقة الافتراضية لضرب متجهين عموديين معاً.
لن يكون منطقياً
التفكير في حاصل ضرب متجهات عمودية هكذا بلغة ضرب المصفوفات لأن الأبعاد لا تعمل بشكل صحيح،
لذا لا يوجد حقاً قلق
بشأن الغموض هنا.
يمكننا أيضاً كتابة
حاصل الضرب التنسوري هكذا داخل كِت ويعني
نفس الشيء بالضبط.
إنه حاصل الضرب التنسوري
للمتجهين.
الأول شائع جداً وفي الواقع الأكثر شيوعاً هو كتابة حاصل الضرب التنسوري هكذا بدون رمز حاصل الضرب التنسوري
من أن نضمّن الرمز. الثاني
بالتأكيد أقل شيوعاً بكثير، لكنه أحياناً مفيد جداً أساساً
كطريقة للتخلص من الحاجة
لأقواس إضافية في حالات معينة.
يمكننا أيضاً التعبير عن
حواصل الضرب التنسورية صراحةً بلغة أعمدة فعلية من
الأرقام كما ترون هنا،
إذا أخذنا حاصل الضرب التنسوري لهذين المتجهين العموديين هنا، فهذا هو المتجه الذي نحصل عليه
ويمكنكم رؤية أن المدخلات هنا هي حواصل ضرب المدخلات
القادمة من هذين المتجهين.
ترتيب مدخلات
حاصل الضرب التنسوري متسق مع
التعريف من قبل قليل بشرط أن نتبع الاتفاقية
التي وصفتها سابقاً لترتيب عناصر
مجموعات الجداء الديكارتي.
اتباع تلك الاتفاقية يكافئ التفكير
في مؤشرات المتجه الأول على أنها
ذات أهمية أعلى من مؤشرات المتجه الثاني،
لذا يمكنكم رؤية أنه
بينما نمر على مدخلات حاصل الضرب التنسوري، لدينا كل حواصل الضرب التي تتضمن المدخلة الأولى من
المتجه الأول على اليسار،
وهي ألفا واحد. ثم كل حواصل الضرب
التي تتضمن المدخلة الثانية من المتجه على اليسار،
وهي ألفا اثنان وهكذا.
إليكم مثالاً حيث
المتجه على اليسار له ثلاث مدخلات والمتجه على
اليمين له أربع مدخلات حتى نتمكن من رؤية
ما يجري بشكل أوضح.
لدينا ثلاث مدخلات في المتجه الأول، لذا نبدأ بكتابة ثلاث نسخ من المتجه الثاني ثم نضرب كل واحدة من تلك النسخ
بالمدخلة المقابلة
في المتجه الأول هكذا.
ندخل الألفات إلى الداخل هكذا، وهنا نحن فقط
نضرب المتجهات بكميات قياسية
وأخيراً نزيل
الأقواس من النسخ ونشكل متجهاً عمودياً
واحداً كما ترون هنا.
كملاحظة مهمة جانبية لاحظوا أن لدينا الصيغ التالية لحاصل الضرب التنسوري
لمتجهات الأساس القياسي.
إذا أخذنا حاصل الضرب
التنسوري لكِت a وكِت b، والذي يمكننا كتابته مع
رمز حاصل الضرب التنسوري أو بدونه، كما ترون هنا،
فالنتيجة هي ببساطة كِت ab.
إذا أردنا كتابة ab كزوج مرتب بدلاً من سلسلة، يمكننا فعل ذلك ونحصل على
هذا التعبير هنا،
لكن الأكثر شيوعاً بكثير
هو كتابته هكذا حيث نحذف الأقواس
لكن نبقي الفاصلة.
هناك معنى يكون فيه
هذا مع الأقواس ربما أكثر صحة، لكنها اتفاقية
قياسية جداً في الرياضيات
أن الأقواس تُزال عندما لا تكون ضرورية أو مفيدة.
يمكنكم اعتبارها ضمنية في هذا هنا وهو ببساطة أقل ازدحاماً
وأجمل للنظر.
حاصل الضرب التنسوري لديه
خاصية مهمة وهي أنه ثنائي الخطية وما يعنيه ذلك هو أنه خطي
في كل من الحجتين بشرط أن تكون الأخرى ثابتة.
بمزيد من التفصيل هو
خطي في الحجة الأولى وهو ما تعبر عنه هاتان المعادلتان اللتان ترونهما هنا،
الأولى تقول أنه
إذا جمعنا متجهين، Phi1 وPhi2 ثم أخذنا
حاصل الضرب التنسوري مع Psi، نحصل على نفس النتيجة لو
أخذنا حاصل الضرب التنسوري
مع Psi أولاً ثم جمعنا.
الثانية تقول أنه إذا
ضربنا متجهاً ما Phi بكمية قياسية ألفا ثم أخذنا
حاصل الضرب التنسوري مع Psi،
تكون النتيجة نفسها كما لو أخذنا حاصل الضرب التنسوري لـ Phi وPsi أولاً ثم ضربنا النتيجة بألفا.
ولدينا أيضاً خطية
في الحجة الثانية وهي نفسها إلا أن أدوار الحجتين مُبدَّلة.
كون حاصل الضرب ثنائي الخطية
أمر مباشر للتحقق من التعريف، لكن من الجيد كتابته هكذا لأننا سنستخدم هذه الصيغ
كثيراً.
لاحظوا بالمناسبة أن الكميات القياسية تتحرك بحرية خلال حواصل الضرب التنسورية بالمعنى الذي تعبر عنه هذه
المساواة التي ترونها هنا.
أي أنه لا فرق
بين ضرب الحجة الأولى بكمية
قياسية ألفا في هذه الحالة ضرب الحجة الثانية
بتلك الكمية القياسية
أو ضرب الشيء
بأكمله بتلك الكمية القياسية.
هذه المساواة تنتج من
هاتين المعادلتين هنا ولأنه لا فرق
بين هذه المتجهات، يمكننا ببساطة كتابة
التعبير كما ترون هنا
بدون أقواس لأنه
لا حاجة لها.
هي لا تضيف أي وضوح
أو تزيل أي غموض، لذا نزيلها ببساطة و
نحصل على تعبير أنظف.
كل هذا يُعمم
لثلاثة أنظمة أو أكثر.
يمكننا تعريف حاصل الضرب التنسوري
لثلاثة متجهات أو أكثر بتعميم الصيغة
لحاصل الضرب التنسوري لمتجهين بالطريقة الطبيعية،
والتي يمكنكم رؤيتها معبراً عنها هنا. كل مدخلة في حاصل الضرب التنسوري تُعطى بحاصل ضرب
المدخلات المقابلة
في المتجهات التي نأخذ
حاصل ضربها التنسوري.
طريقة مكافئة لتعريف
حاصل الضرب التنسوري لثلاثة متجهات أو أكثر
هي فعل ذلك تكرارياً بالرجوع في النهاية إلى تعريف
حاصل الضرب التنسوري بين متجهين. فإذا كان n ثلاثة على الأقل، يمكننا التفكير في
حاصل الضرب التنسوري لـ n من المتجهات
Phi1 حتى Phi n على أنه حاصل الضرب التنسوري بين أي متجه نحصل عليه من
أخذ حاصل الضرب التنسوري لأول n ناقص واحد
منها مع المتجه الأخير،
وإذا أردتم معرفة
ما هو حاصل الضرب التنسوري لأول n ناقص واحد من المتجهات، إما أن تطبقوا الصيغة
مرة أخرى في حالة أن n ناقص واحد
ثلاثة على الأقل أو تستخدموا التعريف
من قبل إذا كان n ناقص واحد يساوي اثنين.
الطريقتان للتفكير في
حواصل الضرب التنسورية لثلاثة متجهات أو أكثر متكافئتان.
هذه المرة عندما يكون لدينا
ثلاثة متجهات أو أكثر نأخذ حاصل ضربها التنسوري، لا نستخدم مصطلح ثنائي الخطية،
بل نستخدم مصطلح متعدد الخطية،
لكن الفكرة نفسها.
حاصل الضرب التنسوري خطي
في كل موقع من المواقع بشرط أن تكون المتجهات في
جميع المواقع الأخرى
ثابتة. بالانتقال إلى قياسات
الأنظمة المتعددة في الحالات الاحتمالية،
نحصل فوراً على مواصفات لكيفية عمل القياسات
للأنظمة المتعددة بمجرد التفكير فيها
مجتمعة كأنظمة مفردة
بشرط أن تُقاس جميع
الأنظمة.
كمثال بسيط، لنفترض أن لدينا بتتين
X وY ومجتمعتان في هذه الحالة الاحتمالية
هنا،
التي رأيناها سابقاً. بطبيعة الحال، إذا قسنا
كلتا البتتين، سنحصل على النتيجة 00
أي صفر للقياس الأول وصفر للقياس الثاني باحتمال نصف وسنحصل على النتيجة 1,1
باحتمال نصف أيضاً. هذا واضح جداً.
في الجوهر، قياس جميع الأنظمة يكافئ قياس
النظام المركب بأكمله.
إذا لم نقس جميع
الأنظمة مع ذلك، بل بدلاً من ذلك قسنا
بعض الأنظمة فقط، فإن الوضع ليس
واضحاً تماماً على الفور
بتقييد انتباهنا مرة أخرى لحالة نظامين فقط
لنرى جوهر ما يحدث في أبسط
إطار ممكن.
يمكننا طرح السؤال التالي، لنفترض أن لدينا نظامين، X وY معاً كزوج
في حالة احتمالية معينة ما.
ماذا يحدث إذا قسنا
X فقط ولم نفعل شيئاً لـ Y؟
حسناً، يمكننا الإجابة على هذا السؤال باستخدام بعض نظرية الاحتمالات الأساسية.
أولاً، نعلم أن احتمال أن يعطي القياس
نتيجة معينة يجب أن يُعطى بهذه الصيغة
التي ترونها هنا.
يمكننا التفكير في الاحتمالات لكل حالة
كلاسيكية للزوج XY كما لو أننا قسنا كليهما ونجمع كل الاحتمالات
المتسقة مع كون X في أي حالة كلاسيكية
a نهتم بها.
لهذا السبب المجموع هنا هو فقط على الحالات الكلاسيكية b لـ Y.
إحدى طرق التفكير في هذه
الصيغة هي أن احتمال رؤية حالة كلاسيكية
معينة لـ X إذا قسناه
يجب أن يكون متسقاً مع احتمال رؤية تلك الحالة لو
أننا قسنا Y أيضاً، حتى لو لم نفعل،
هذا طبيعي وبديهي جداً. احتمال أن يعطي قياس X نتيجة معينة لا يمكن أن يعتمد على ما إذا كان Y
قد قيس أيضاً
بغض النظر عن النتيجة.
إذن هذا يخبرنا ما هي
الاحتمالات للنتائج المختلفة الممكنة
للقياس، لكن ماذا يحدث لـ Y أو معرفتنا
عن Y نتيجة لذلك؟
الإجابة هي أنه لا يزال
يمكن أن يوجد بعض عدم اليقين حول حالة Y كنتيجة
لقياس X
ورؤية نتيجة معينة. وعدم اليقين هذا يُمثَّل بهذه الصيغة هنا للاحتمال الشرطي
بأن Y في حالة كلاسيكية
معينة b، بالنظر إلى أن X في حالة كلاسيكية ما،
أي حالة كلاسيكية a،
صادف أننا قسناها.
لنكون دقيقين، احتمال أن يكون Y
في حالة كلاسيكية ما b، بالنظر إلى أن X في الحالة الكلاسيكية a،
يساوي احتمال
أن X في a وY في b مقسوماً على احتمال أن X
في الحالة الكلاسيكية a.
إذن إذا قسنا X، سنرى
حالات كلاسيكية مختلفة باحتمالات تحددها
هذه الصيغة هنا
وبحسب النتيجة التي نحصل عليها، قد يبقى لدينا بعض عدم اليقين حول الحالة الكلاسيكية لـ Y وعدم
اليقين هذا ينعكس
في هذه الصيغة هنا.
هناك في الواقع طريقة سهلة جداً
لإعادة صياغة كل هذا ولإجراء الحسابات
لحالات محددة باستخدام ترميز ديراك
وتسير هكذا.
نبدأ بكتابة الحالة
الاحتمالية لـ XY كمتجه هكذا، وهذا
عام تماماً.
المدخلات يُرمز لها بـ Pab وهذه يمكن أن تكون أي أرقام طالما أن المتجه بأكمله
هو متجه احتمال.
يمكننا التعبير عن كِت ab كحاصل
ضرب تنسوري كما ترون هنا ثم يمكننا استخدام
ثنائية خطية حاصل الضرب التنسوري
وتحديداً كونه خطياً في الحجة الثانية للتعبير عن هذا المتجه
كما ترون هنا.
ما نفعله هو عزل متجهات الأساس القياسي
على الجانب الأيسر فعلياً ووضع ما نحتاجه
على الجانب الأيمن
للسماح بذلك لأن هذا سيكشف ما يحدث عندما
نقيس النظام الأول X.
تحديداً احتمال
الحصول على نتيجة معينة a هو مجموع كل الاحتمالات التي تظهر في
الأقواس بجانب كِت a.
وبشرط الحصول على
نتيجة معينة a، متجه الاحتمال الذي يصف أي عدم يقين متبقٍ حول Y
هو المتجه الذي كان في
الأقواس بجانب a.
إلا أننا يجب أن نطبعه لنجعله متجه احتمال وذلك يعني أنه
يجب أن نقسم ذلك المتجه
على مجموع مدخلات ذلك المتجه لتشكيل متجه احتمال.
هنا بالمناسبة، المجموع يُؤخذ على كل
c في جاما بدلاً من b فقط لاستخدام اسم متغير مختلف حتى لا يكون هناك خلط
حول نطاق المتغيرات
إن صح التعبير.
المجاميع في البسط
والمقام يجب اعتبارها أشياء منفصلة ويمكننا تجنب أي فرصة
للخلط حول ذلك
باستخدام متغيرات
مختلفة للمجموعين.
إليكم مثالاً سريعاً
لتوضيح كيف يعمل كل هذا.
لنفترض أن XY زوج من البتات في هذه الحالة الاحتمالية هنا لفهم ما يحدث
عندما نقيس البت الأول
ولا نفعل شيئاً للثاني، نكتب المتجه كما ترون هنا حيث كِت صفر وكِت
واحد في الموقع الأول
معزولان تماماً كما
وصفنا قبل لحظات.
الاحتمال الأول هو
أن تكون نتيجة القياس صفراً واحتمال
حدوث ذلك هو مجموع الاحتمالات
داخل الأقواس
المضروبة تنسورياً بكِت صفر. فنحصل على واحد على اثني عشر زائد ربع، وهو ثلث و
بشرط النتيجة صفر.
الحالة الاحتمالية لـ Y
تصبح هذا المتجه مُطبَّعاً أو ما يكافئ مقسوماً على الاحتمال
الذي حسبناه للتو، وما نحصل عليه هو
هذا المتجه هنا.
الاحتمال الثاني هو أن تكون نتيجة القياس واحداً والحساب يتم
بطريقة مماثلة باستخدام الحد الثاني في التعبير
بدلاً من الحد الأول. وإذا أردتم التحقق من التفاصيل، تفضلوا كالعادة وأوقفوا الفيديو لتمنحوا أنفسكم لحظة لفعل ذلك.
يمكنكم إجراء نفس
أنواع الحسابات لمعرفة ما يحدث عندما
يُقاس Y بدلاً من X.
إنها نفس الطريقة مع تناظر بين النظامين.
هذه المرة نكتب
متجه الاحتمال هكذا، مع عزل متجهات الأساس القياسي على اليمين كما ترون هنا،
لكن بخلاف ذلك يعمل
بنفس الطريقة تماماً.
يمكنكم أيضاً استخدام هذه الطريقة
لأكثر من نظامين.
يمكن أن يصبح الأمر فوضوياً
قليلاً لمجرد كتابة كل التعبيرات المطلوبة، لكن مفاهيمياً هي
نفس الفكرة بالضبط.
أخيراً، في جزء الدرس المتعلق
بالمعلومات الكلاسيكية، سنلقي نظرة على العمليات
على الحالات الاحتمالية
للأنظمة المتعددة. باتباع نفس المنطق الذي رأيناه الآن عدة مرات.
نستنتج أن العمليات الاحتمالية على الأنظمة المتعددة هي تماماً
مثل العمليات الاحتمالية على الأنظمة المفردة المُمثلة
بمصفوفات عشوائية.
لكن هذه المرة تلك المصفوفات
لها صفوف وأعمدة تقابل الجداء الديكارتي لمجموعات الحالات
الكلاسيكية للأنظمة الفردية.
أي أننا ببساطة
نرى النظام المركب كأنه نظام مفرد ونرجع إلى الوصف لكيفية عمل العمليات الاحتمالية
للأنظمة المفردة من
الدرس السابق.
إليكم مثالاً على عملية تسمى عملية NOT
المتحكم بها على بتتين X وY.
هذه في الواقع عملية حتمية وطريقة عملها هي
أنه إذا كان X يساوي واحداً، فإن عملية NOT تُجرى على Y
وإلا إذا كان X يساوي
صفراً فلا يحدث شيء.
البت X يُسمى أحياناً
بت التحكم لأنه يحدد ما إذا كانت
عملية NOT تُطبق على Y أم لا
وY يُسمى البت الهدف لأنه البت الذي تُطبق عليه عملية NOT.
يمكنكم أيضاً تخيل
تبديل أدوار X وY بحيث يصبح Y بت التحكم
وX يصبح الهدف، لكن هذه عملية مختلفة
عن المذكورة هنا لأن العملية ليست
متناظرة بين X وY.
كلتاهما تسمى
عمليات NOT المتحكم بها، ونحتاج فقط لتحديد
أي بت هو بت التحكم و
أيهما البت الهدف.
هذه العملية لها التأثير
الذي ترونه هنا على حالات الأساس القياسي ويمكنكم التحقق من ذلك
التأثير مقابل تعريف
العملية. وإليكم التمثيل المصفوفي
للعملية.
عندما نفكر في هذه العملية، لدينا في ذهننا أن هناك
بتتين منفصلتين وتلعبان الأدوار التي وصفتها للتو مع
كون X بت التحكم
وY البت الهدف، لكن ليس هناك حقاً شيء
في هذا التأثير هنا أو هذا التمثيل المصفوفي
يفرض أن نفكر
في هاتين البتتين كبتتين منفصلتين.
يمكننا بدلاً من ذلك ببساطة
التفكير في هذه العملية كعملية حتمية
على نظام له أربع حالات كلاسيكية
قررنا تسميتها
0,0 و0,1 و1,0 و1,1.
إليكم مثالاً آخر على
عملية احتمالية على بتتين، وهي ليست عملية حتمية
هذه المرة.
العملية تجعل Y مساوياً لـ X باحتمال نصف وإلا تسير بالاتجاه المعاكس وتجعل X مساوياً لـ Y.
هذه العملية ليس لها اسم خاص هي فقط مثال.
وإليكم التمثيل المصفوفي
لهذه العملية.
يمكنكم رؤية أنها يمكن التعبير عنها كمتوسط لمصفوفتين، واحدة تمثل العملية
الحتمية
حيث يُضبط Y على أي
قيمة مخزنة في X والأخرى تضبط
X ليساوي Y.
إذن نرى هنا أنه يمكننا أخذ متوسطات المصفوفات العشوائية للحصول على مصفوفات جديدة تماماً كما كان في الدرس السابق.
الآن، لنأخذ بعين الاعتبار
السؤال التالي. لنفترض أن لدينا عمليتين
احتماليتين كل منهما على نظامها الخاص
موصوفتين كالمعتاد بمصفوفات عشوائية
وللدقة، لنفترض أن M هي
عملية احتمالية
على نظام X وN هي
عملية احتمالية على نظام Y.
السؤال هو إذا أجرينا
M على X وN على Y في نفس الوقت، كيف ننسب
التأثير الذي يحدثه هذا
على النظام المركب XY؟
بالتفكير في هذا
بشكل حدسي للحظة، إذا أجرينا
العمليتين في نفس الوقت على أنظمتهما المعنية،
فإننا في الواقع
نجري عملية على النظام المركب، لذا يجب وصفها
بمصفوفة عشوائية ما.
الإجابة المختصرة على هذا
السؤال هي أن المصفوفة تُحصل عليها بأخذ حاصل ضرب تنسوري، ليس بين متجهات كما
تحدثنا سابقاً،
لكن بين مصفوفات في هذه
الحالة، المصفوفتان M وN.
لنأخذ بضع لحظات
لمناقشة حواصل الضرب التنسورية للمصفوفات ثم
سنعود إلى هذا السؤال.
إليكم تعريف
حاصل الضرب التنسوري بين المصفوفات وهو
مشابه جداً لحاصل الضرب التنسوري بين المتجهات.
إذا افترضنا أن المصفوفتين
اللتين نعمل معهما مكتوبتان بالصيغ التي ترونها هنا بحيث أن مدخلات M يُرمز لها بألفا ab حيث a وb
تمتدان على مجموعة حالات كلاسيكية سيجما ومدخلات N يُرمز لها
ببيتا cd حيث c وd
تمتدان على مجموعة حالات كلاسيكية جاما.
فإن حاصل ضرب M وN هو المصفوفة التي ترونها هنا.
ما لدينا مشابه
لحاصل الضرب التنسوري بين المتجهات.
صفوف وأعمدة M تنسور N تقابل أزواج الحالات الكلاسيكية المكتوبة كسلاسل هنا،
والمدخلات هي حواصل ضرب المدخلات المقابلة لـ M وN.
إليكم طريقة أخرى لكتابتها بلغة المدخلات الفردية
لهذه المصفوفات.
المدخلة ac bd لـ M تنسور N هي حاصل ضرب المدخلة ab
لـ M والمدخلة cd لـ N.
هناك طريقة أخرى لوصف
M تنسور N، وهي أنها المصفوفة
الوحيدة التي تحول أي متجه بصيغة Phi تنسور Psi
إلى حاصل الضرب التنسوري لـ M مطبقة على Phi مع N مطبقة على Psi، ويجب أن يكون هذا صحيحاً لكل اختيار
لهذين المتجهين Phi وPsi.
إحدى طرق التفكير في
هذا هي أن حاصل الضرب التنسوري للمصفوفات يتوافق تماماً مع حاصل الضرب التنسوري بين المتجهات.
هذه معادلة كنتم تأملون بطبيعة الحال
أن تكون صحيحة وهي بالفعل كذلك.
بلغة المصفوفات المكتوبة
صراحة، يمكننا تعريف حاصل الضرب
التنسوري كما ترون هنا.
هناك الكثير من النقاط في هذه المعادلة والمقصود منها
توضيح النمط، وهو نفس النمط
الذي كان لدينا للمتجهات إلا أن لدينا الآن صفوفاً وأعمدة
بدلاً من مجرد متجهات عمودية.
في حال لم يكن واضحاً، المثال
التالي قد يساعد.
هنا نتحدث عن
حاصل الضرب التنسوري لمصفوفتين اثنتين في اثنتين.
نكتب أولاً أربع نسخ
من المصفوفة الثانية، واحدة لكل مدخلة في المصفوفة الأولى.
نضرب كل واحدة من هذه
النسخ من المصفوفة الثانية بالمدخلة المقابلة
في المصفوفة الأولى،
ثم نجمع كل ذلك في
مصفوفة أربعة في أربعة واحدة كما ترون هنا.
يمكننا أيضاً تعريف
حاصل الضرب التنسوري لثلاث مصفوفات أو أكثر بطريقة مماثلة وربما أسهل
طريقة للتعبير عن هذا
هي كما ترون هنا
حيث لدينا صيغة لكل مدخلة في حاصل الضرب التنسوري، وهي ببساطة حاصل ضرب
المدخلات المقابلة.
يمكنكم أيضاً تعريف حاصل الضرب التنسوري لثلاث مصفوفات أو أكثر تكرارياً بلغة حاصل الضرب
التنسوري لمصفوفتين فقط تماماً كما كان لدينا للمتجهات.
وملاحظة أخيرة هي
أن حاصل الضرب التنسوري للمصفوفات تضاعفي، مما يعني أن حاصل ضرب
حواصل الضرب التنسورية
يساوي حاصل الضرب التنسوري
لحواصل الضرب.
يمكنكم التفكير في
هذا كتعميم للصيغة من قبل قليل لتأثير حاصل الضرب التنسوري
للمصفوفات
على حاصل الضرب التنسوري للمتجهات. ومرة أخرى، هذا شيء
كنا بالتأكيد نأمل أن يكون صحيحاً ويمكننا أن نكون سعداء بأنه كذلك
وسنستفيد من هذه
الحقيقة كلما احتجنا.
والآن يمكننا العودة إلى
السؤال من قبل الذي يسأل كيف نصف
تأثير إجراء عملية M على نظام X
وعملية N على نظام Y معاً كعملية
على النظام المركب XY.
والإجابة على ذلك
السؤال هي أن التأثير يوصف بحاصل
الضرب التنسوري لـ M وN.
حواصل الضرب التنسورية تمثل الاستقلال هذه المرة بين العمليات بدلاً مما رأيناه
سابقاً لمتجهات الاحتمال.
إليكم مثالاً سريعاً. لنفترض أننا نجري
العملية الاحتمالية الموصوفة بهذه المصفوفة على بت X.
هذه بالصدفة عملية
رأيناها في الدرس الأول ونجري في نفس الوقت
عملية NOT على بت Y.
العملية المدمجة على الزوج XY تُمثل إذن بحاصل الضرب التنسوري للمصفوفات المقابلة لهاتين العمليتين.
إليكم تلك الخاصة بـ X و
إليكم عملية NOT على Y ونحصل على هذه المصفوفة
التي ترونها هنا.
ويمكنكم رؤية أنها بالفعل
مصفوفة عشوائية وسيكون هذا هو الحال دائماً.
حاصل الضرب التنسوري لأي
مصفوفتين عشوائيتين أو أي عدد من المصفوفات
العشوائية لهذا الشأن سيكون دائماً عشوائياً.
إنه وضع شائع جداً
أن نواجه حالة تُجرى فيها عملية واحدة على
نظام ولا يُفعل شيء لنظام آخر.
في هذه الحالة، نتبع نفس الوصفة تماماً مع فهم أن عدم فعل شيء يُمثل بمصفوفة الوحدة.
على سبيل المثال، إذا كان لدينا بتتان X و
Y وأعدنا ضبط البت X إلى حالة الصفر، وهو نفس الشيء
مثل إجراء دالة الصفر
الثابتة على X ولم نفعل شيئاً لـ Y، فإن العملية الناتجة على الزوج XY
تُمثل بحاصل الضرب
التنسوري هذا هنا.
كل هذا يُعمم
لأي عدد من الأنظمة وسنرى بعض الأمثلة الإضافية عندما ننتقل إلى السياق الكمي، الذي يعمل بنفس الطريقة تماماً
إلا أن لدينا مصفوفات أحادية بدلاً من مصفوفات عشوائية، وهذا يكفي عن
المعلومات الكلاسيكية الآن.
الآن سنوجه انتباهنا
إلى المعلومات الكمية وكيف تعمل للأنظمة المتعددة.
النمط هو نفسه كما كان
للمعلومات الكلاسيكية.
يمكننا رؤية أنظمة كمية متعددة كأنظمة مركبة مفردة وتطبيق ما نعرفه
من الدرس السابق.
مرة أخرى، حواصل الضرب التنسورية
ستلعب دوراً رئيسياً وبشكل عام نحصل على وصف لكيفية عمل المعلومات الكمية
للأنظمة المتعددة.
وهو مشابه جداً
ومتماثل رياضياً لما رأيناه للتو للمعلومات
الكلاسيكية.
سنبدأ بالحالات الكمية.
الحالات الكمية للأنظمة المتعددة تُمثل بمتجهات عمودية ذات مدخلات أعداد مركبة
ومعيار إقليدي يساوي واحداً
تماماً مثل الحالات الكمية
للأنظمة المفردة.
هذه المرة مؤشرات
متجهات الحالة الكمية تقابل الجداء الديكارتي لمجموعات الحالات الكلاسيكية
للأنظمة الفردية
لأنه مرة أخرى، هذه هي
مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية للنظام المركب.
على سبيل المثال، إذا كان X وY عبارة عن qubit، فإن مجموعة الحالات
الكلاسيكية للزوج XY معاً هي الجداء الديكارتي للأبجدية
الثنائية مع نفسها،
والتي يمكننا التفكير فيها
كمجموعة جميع السلاسل الثنائية بطول اثنين.
إذن هذه المتجهات التي ترونها هنا كلها أمثلة على متجهات
حالة كمية لـ XY.
إذا أردنا، يمكننا بدلاً من ذلك كتابة
هذه المتجهات هكذا حيث لدينا كِت منفصل
لكل qubit
حيث حاصل الضرب التنسوري
بينهما ضمني.
أو يمكننا أيضاً كتابة
رمز حاصل الضرب التنسوري صراحة هكذا إن فضلتم.
وخيار آخر هو
إضافة اسم النظام كمنخفض للكِتات
التي تمثلها هكذا.
ويمكنكم فعل هذا مع
رمز حاصل الضرب التنسوري أو بدونه.
يمكن أن يكون هذا مفيداً جداً أحياناً لإبقاء الأمور واضحة.
هذه مجرد أنماط مختلفة للتعبير عن نفس المتجهات ويمكننا اختيار أيها نريد أو أيها نفضل أو
أيها الأكثر منطقية
للوضع الراهن. عندما تصبح الأمور أكثر
تعقيداً مثلاً، قد نقرر أن أحد
هذه الأنماط يضيف وضوحاً
ونحن أحرار في اتخاذ
أي خيار نريد.
حواصل الضرب التنسورية لمتجهات الحالة الكمية هي أيضاً متجهات حالة كمية.
لحالة نظامين مثلاً، إذا كان Phi متجه حالة كمية
لنظام X وPsi متجه حالة كمية
لنظام Y،
فإن حاصل الضرب التنسوري لـ Phi وPsi هو متجه حالة كمية لـ XY.
نسمي حالات كهذه حالات حاصل ضرب ومشابهة لما رأيناه في السياق الاحتمالي الكلاسيكي، فهي تمثل الاستقلال
بين النظامين X وY.
فعلى سبيل المثال، إذا كان لدى شخص مختبر
في جزء من العالم وأنشأ نظاماً X وهيّأه إلى الحالة الكمية Phi
وشخص آخر في
جزء آخر من العالم هيّأ بشكل مستقل نظاماً Y إلى الحالة الكمية Psi،
فإذا اخترنا التفكير في XY كنظام واحد رغم أن جزأيه في أجزاء مختلفة من العالم،
فإن النظام المركب XY يكون
في الحالة Phi تنسور Psi.
كل هذا يُعمم
لأكثر من نظامين بالطريقة الطبيعية.
إذا كان لدينا حالات
كمية Psi1 حتى PsiN لأنظمة منفصلة X1 حتى Xn، فإن حاصل الضرب التنسوري لهذه المتجهات الـ n
يمثل حالة كمية، تسمى أيضاً حالة حاصل ضرب للنظام المركب X1 حتى Xn.
إليكم مثالاً على حالة
كمية لاثنين من qubit.
رغم أنها قد لا تبدو
كذلك فوراً. هي مثال على حالة حاصل ضرب لأنه يمكننا كتابتها
كحاصل ضرب تنسوري كما ترون هنا.
إذن هي مثال على حالة
حاصل ضرب بغض النظر عن كيفية كتابتها، المهم هو ما إذا
كان ممكناً كتابتها كحاصل ضرب تنسوري أم لا.
هذه الحالة الكمية، مع ذلك، وهي أيضاً حالة لاثنين من
qubit ليست حالة حاصل ضرب.
هي مشابهة في الروح للمثال
الذي رأيناه في السياق الاحتمالي لبتتين عشوائيتين مترابطتين تماماً
ونفس البرهان يكشف أنها لا يمكن كتابتها
كحاصل ضرب تنسوري.
لننقل هذا إلى هنا ولنلق نظرة على البرهان بمزيد من التفصيل.
لنتخيل أنه يمكننا
كتابة هذه الحالة كحاصل ضرب تنسوري
لمتجهين Phi وPsi.
المدخلة المقابلة
للحالة الكلاسيكية 0,1 هي صفر لهذا المتجه، وهو ما يمكننا رؤيته بمجرد النظر إليه.
لكن هذا سيعني، لو كان المتجه حاصل ضرب
تنسوري لمتجهين أن المدخلة صفر لـ Phi
ضرب المدخلة واحد لـ Psi
ستساوي صفراً، لكن هذا يعني أن إما
المدخلة صفر لـ Phi أو المدخلة واحد لـ Psi تساوي صفراً
أو كلاهما يمكن أن يساوي صفراً، لكن هذا يتناقض مع حقيقة
أن هذين الحاصلين هنا يجب أن يكونا غير صفريين.
هما يساويان واحداً
على جذر اثنين. البرهان في الواقع مطابق تقريباً
لما كان لدينا في السياق الاحتمالي.
لا يوجد شيء كمي فريد
في هذا على الإطلاق.
في كل الأحوال، ما نجده هو أن الحالة الأصلية ليست حالة حاصل ضرب.
لاحظوا أنه ليس مهماً
أن هذين العددين هنا هما واحد على جذر اثنين.
كل ما يهم هو أن
كلتا القيمتين غير صفريتين.
هذه الحالة الكمية بالذات
مثيرة للاهتمام جداً. هي مثال على حالة
متشابكة لاثنين من qubit.
سنتحدث أكثر عن
التشابك لاحقاً في السلسلة.
التشابك يمكن أن يكون معقداً، خاصة عندما
نتحدث عن الحالات الكمية في الصياغة العامة
للمعلومات الكمية،
لكن هنا في الوصف المبسط للمعلومات الكمية التشابك يكافئ غياب الاستقلال.
فبالنسبة لمتجه حالة كمية،
إذا لم يكن حالة حاصل ضرب، فهو حالة متشابكة
وهذه الحالة بالذات
يُنظر إليها عادة على أنها
المثال النموذجي لحالة كمية متشابكة.
وفي الواقع، أحياناً
نفكر في هذه الحالة على أنها تمثل وحدة واحدة من التشابك، خاصة عندما
نفكر في التشابك
كمورد يمكن استخدامه
لفعل أشياء مثيرة للاهتمام.
الحالة الكمية التي
تحدثنا عنها للتو هي واحدة من حالات Bell الأربع المعروفة، والتي يمكنكم رؤيتها هنا
مع الأسماء
المستخدمة عادة لهذه الحالات، Phi plus وPhi minus
وPsi plus وPsi minus.
كلها متشابكة
وتشكل بالفعل أساساً لفضاء جميع
المتجهات الممثلة لحالات اثنين من qubit.
إذن هذه المتجهات الأربعة معاً
تسمى أساس Bell.
إنها مجموعة شائعة جداً
من الحالات الكمية سُميت
تكريماً لـ John Bell، الذي كان فيزيائياً قدم
مساهمات مهمة جداً
في دراسة التشابك في ستينيات القرن العشرين.
إليكم بعض الأمثلة المعروفة على حالات كمية لثلاثة من qubit.
الأولى تسمى حالة GHZ.
هي نوعاً ما مثل حالة Phi
plus التي رأيناها للتو إلا لثلاثة من qubit بدلاً من اثنين.
والمثال الثاني يسمى حالة W ويبدو كما ترون هنا، فهي منتظمة على
السلاسل الثنائية الثلاث
بطول ثلاثة التي فيها
بت واحد بالضبط مضبوط على واحد.
لا واحدة من هذه الحالات هي حالة حاصل ضرب وكلتاهما لها خصائص مثيرة للاهتمام وتظهر بشكل شائع كأمثلة، لذا من الجيد معرفتها
وسنراها مرة أخرى.
بعد ذلك سنتحدث عن
قياسات الأنظمة في الحالات الكمية.
باتباع نفس المنطق
الذي اتبعناه حتى الآن في الدرس، وهو التفكير في الأنظمة المتعددة
كأنها أنظمة مفردة. نصل فوراً إلى وصف لكيفية عمل قياسات
الأنظمة الكمية المتعددة
بشرط أن تُقاس جميع
الأنظمة.
أي إذا كان لدينا
متجه حالة كمية Psi يمثل حالة
كمية لصف n من الأنظمة
X1 حتى Xn وقسنا
النظام المركب بأكمله، وهو ما يكافئ قياس
كل واحد من الأنظمة الفردية، فإن كل صف n ممكن
من الحالات الكلاسيكية سيكون نتيجة القياس
باحتمال يساوي
مربع القيمة المطلقة لمدخلة Psi التي
تقابل ذلك الصف n.
على سبيل المثال، إذا كان
لدينا زوج من الأنظمة XY في هذه الحالة الكمية هنا، فإذا قسنا كلا النظامين،
فسنحصل على النتيجة صفر قلوب أي صفر لقياس X وقلوب لقياس Y
باحتمال تسعة على خمسة وعشرين وسنحصل على النتيجة واحد
بستوني باحتمال ستة عشر على خمسة وعشرين.
هذا واضح جداً حقاً. نحن أساساً نتجاهل حقيقة أن هذين نظامان منفصلان ونراهما كأنهما
نظام واحد،
لكن هذا يطرح السؤال
الطبيعي التالي، الذي سبق أن نظرنا فيه
في السياق الكلاسيكي.
لنفترض أن لدينا نظامين X وY مجتمعين
في حالة كمية ما ولم نقس كليهما، بل
قسنا نظاماً واحداً فقط.
لنقل أننا قسنا النظام X ولم نفعل شيئاً لـ Y.
بالطبع، يمكننا أيضاً أن نسأل ماذا يحدث إذا قسنا Y وليس
X وبشكل أعم ماذا يحدث إذا كان لدينا
ثلاثة أنظمة أو أكثر
وقسنا مجموعة جزئية حقيقية منها. لكن بمجرد أن نحصل على
إجابة لهذا السؤال، ستكون لدينا إجابات على
تلك الأسئلة أيضاً.
نعلم أنه بشكل عام
متجه حالة كمية للزوج XY يأخذ
الصيغة التي ترونها هنا، بافتراض كالمعتاد أن سيجما وجاما
هما مجموعتا الحالات الكلاسيكية
لـ X وY على التوالي.
مدخلات هذا المتجه يُرمز
لها بألفا ab ممتدة على كل الاختيارات الممكنة لـ a وb،
ويمكن أن تكون أي عدد مركب يجعل هذا المتجه
متجه وحدة.
الآن نعلم بالفعل أنه إذا
قيس كلا النظامين، فنحصل على الاحتمالات للنتائج الممكنة المختلفة
بأخذ مربع القيمة المطلقة للمدخلة المقابلة.
وبالتالي إذا قيس X فقط، فإن احتمال
الحصول على نتيجة معينة a يُعطى بهذا التعبير،
نجمع ببساطة على كل
النتائج الممكنة b، التي يمكن الحصول عليها
لو قيس Y أيضاً رغم أنه لم يُقس.
الفكرة هي نفسها كما في
السياق الاحتمالي.
احتمال الحصول على
نتيجة معينة عند قياس X لا يمكن
أن يعتمد على ما إذا قيس Y أيضاً أم لا.
إذن هذا يخبرنا ما هي
الاحتمالات للنتائج الممكنة المختلفة.
بالإضافة إلى ذلك، سيكون هناك
تغير في حالة Y نتيجة إجراء
هذا القياس على X والحصول على نتيجة معينة.
لنلقِ نظرة على كيفية عمل هذا.
مشابهاً لما فعلناه في
السياق الاحتمالي، يمكننا التعبير عن
متجه الحالة الكمية Psi كما ترون هنا
حيث Phi a هو هذا المتجه لكل اختيار لحالة كلاسيكية a من النظام X،
نحن نستخدم ثنائية الخطية
لحاصل الضرب التنسوري تماماً كما قبل.
فقط الآن اخترنا تسمية
هذه المتجهات المختلفة Phi a، للسهولة فقط.
لاحظنا بالفعل أن احتمال أن يعطي القياس
كل نتيجة ممكنة a هو كما ترون هنا،
لكن الآن يمكننا رؤية أن هذا الاحتمال يساوي مربع المعيار الإقليدي
للمتجه Phi a،
والآن نتيجة قياس X وإعطاء نتيجة معينة a، فإن الحالة الكمية
للنظام المركب XY
تصبح هذه الحالة التي
ترونها هنا.
تماماً كما كان لدينا للأنظمة المفردة، الحالة تنهار جوهرياً، لكنها لا تنهار
بالكامل بشكل عام،
هي تنهار فقط بالقدر اللازم لتكون متسقة
مع قياس X الذي أعطى النتيجة a.
الحالة الكمية لـ Y تصبح Phi a مُطبَّعة أي أننا
نقسم على معيارها الإقليدي
لتصبح متجه وحدة. هذا مماثل لما حدث في
السياق الاحتمالي حيث بدلاً من القسمة
على المعيار الإقليدي،
قسمنا على مجموع
مدخلات Phi a للحصول على متجه احتمال.
لكن هنا لأننا نتحدث
عن حالات كمية، نقسم على المعيار الإقليدي
للحصول على متجه حالة كمية.
لنلقِ نظرة على بعض الأمثلة لنرى كيف يعمل هذا
لحالة محددة.
إليكم الحالة التي سننظر فيها. نفترض أن X وY عبارة عن qubit وهما في هذه الحالة المعينة Psi.
ولنفترض أن X قيس.
نبدأ بكتابة الحالة
Psi كما ترون هنا، مع عزل عوامل الأساس القياسي
لـ X فعلياً
وضربها تنسورياً مع ما نحتاجه للحصول على الحالة الأصلية.
تماماً كما في الوصف العام
من قبل قليل.
احتمال الحصول على النتيجة صفر هو مربع المعيار الإقليدي
لهذا المتجه هنا.
الشيء الذي نضربه تنسورياً مع كِت صفر في تعبيرنا عن المتجه Psi.
وبالتالي الاحتمال هو ثلاثة أرباع وبشرط
الحصول على النتيجة صفر.
الحالة الكمية
للزوج XY تصبح هذه حيث نطبع
المتجه المضروب تنسورياً مع كِت صفر،
وهذا يكافئ
القسمة على الجذر التربيعي للاحتمال الذي
حسبناه للتو.
يمكننا عندها التبسيط
وهذا ما نحصل عليه.
احتمال الحصول على نتيجة
القياس واحد يُحسب بطريقة مماثلة.
نأخذ مربع المعيار الإقليدي
لهذا المتجه هنا. الشيء المضروب تنسورياً مع كِت
واحد في تعبيرنا عن Psi
والاحتمال الناتج
هو ربع، وهو ما يجب أن يكون بالطبع، لأن احتمالاتنا
يجب أن يكون مجموعها واحد.
في هذه الحالة، الحالة الكمية لـ XY تصبح هذه حيث مرة أخرى نطبع بالقسمة على المعيار الإقليدي
حتى نحصل على متجه الحالة
الكمية هذا كنتيجة.
نفس الطريقة تُستخدم
بشكل متناظر، إذا قيس Y بدلاً من X.
إليكم متجه الحالة الكمية الأصلي، وهذه المرة لأن Y
هو الذي قيس بدلاً من X،
نعبر عن المتجه Psi
كما ترون هنا، حيث هذه المرة نعزل
متجهات الأساس القياسي لـ Y
بدلاً من X ونضربها تنسورياً
مع ما نحتاجه للحصول على تعبير لـ Psi.
بالمرور على الحساب، الذي يمكنكم التحقق منه
بإيقاف الفيديو إن أردتم.
نرى أن احتمال
الحصول على النتيجة صفر هو خمسة أثمان هذه المرة، وإليكم
متجه الحالة الكمية
الناتج بشرط
الحصول على تلك النتيجة.
واحتمال الحصول على
النتيجة واحد هو ثلاثة أثمان، وفي هذه الحالة هذا هو
متجه حالتنا الكمية.
يمكنكم استخدام نفس الطريقة بالضبط في حالة وجود أكثر من نظامين وأي مجموعة جزئية حقيقية
منهم تُقاس.
وهناك مثال في
محتوى الكتاب الدراسي لهذا الدرس يمكنكم
الاطلاع عليه إن كنتم مهتمين.
باختصار، يمكننا دائماً تقسيم الأنظمة إلى مجموعتين منفصلتين، تلك التي تُقاس
وتلك التي لا تُقاس.
وبمجرد أن نفعل ذلك، نرجع إلى الطريقة
التي وصفتها للتو، وهكذا تعمل القياسات للأنظمة الكمية المتعددة.
والآن أخيراً، ننتقل إلى العمليات الأحادية
على الأنظمة المتعددة.
باستخدام نفس الفكرة الأساسية أن الأنظمة المتعددة يمكن رؤيتها كأنظمة مركبة مفردة.
نستنتج ما ترون مكتوباً
هنا على الشاشة، العمليات الكمية على الأنظمة المركبة تُمثل بمصفوفات أحادية
تماماً كما لدينا للأنظمة المفردة وتحديداً صفوف وأعمدة تلك المصفوفات الأحادية تقابل الجداء الديكارتي
لمجموعات الحالات الكلاسيكية لأي مجموعة من
الأنظمة نتحدث عنها.
على سبيل المثال، إذا كان لدينا نظام X
حالاته الكلاسيكية هي واحد واثنان وثلاثة وY عبارة عن qubit،
فإن المصفوفة التي ترونها هنا هي مثال على مصفوفة أحادية تمثل
عملية على الزوج XY.
تفاصيل كيفية ترتيب
الجداءات الديكارتية التي تحدثنا عنها سابقاً لا تهم حقاً لغرض
هذا المثال، إنها مجرد مصفوفة ستة في ستة
تصادف أنها أحادية.
ليس فيها شيء مميز، رغم أنها مبنية من
بعض المصفوفات المهمة.
النقطة هي أنه يمكنكم
اختيار أي مصفوفة أحادية ستة في ستة وستمثل
عملية أحادية على XY.
إذا طبقنا مجموعة من
العمليات الأحادية بشكل مستقل كل منها على نظامها الخاص، فإن تأثيرها جميعاً معاً
على النظام المركب يُعطى
بحاصل الضرب التنسوري.
وهنا على الشاشة يمكنكم رؤية صياغة أكثر دقة
لتلك الحقيقة.
إذا كانت عملياتنا الأحادية موصوفة بالمصفوفات الأحادية U1 حتى Un واحدة لكل نظام من أنظمتنا،
فإن التأثير المدمج
على النظام المركب يُعطى بحاصل الضرب
التنسوري لـ U1 حتى Un.
مرة أخرى، مشابهاً لما كان لدينا في السياق الاحتمالي، مثال مهم هو أننا
نطبق عملية أحادية ما
U على نظام X ولا نفعل
شيئاً لنظام آخر Y.
العملية على XY التي نحصل عليها هي U مضروبة تنسورياً مع مصفوفة الوحدة.
مصفوفة الوحدة
تصف عدم فعل شيء لـ Y.
أحياناً من المفيد كتابة صراحة أن مصفوفة الوحدة هذه
تقابل النظام Y، فقط لجعل الصيغ أوضح.
وأحد الخيارات هو
إعطاء مصفوفة الوحدة منخفضاً هكذا يشير إلى النظام الذي تعمل عليه.
عندما يكون الأمر واضحاً بما يكفي، عادة لا نهتم
بالمنخفض، لكن عندما تصبح الأمور أكثر تعقيداً، يمكن أن يكون مفيداً جداً.
ويمكننا أيضاً النظر في
الحالة المتناظرة حيث عملية أحادية
ما V تُطبق على Y ولا يُفعل شيء لـ X،
وهذه المرة العملية الأحادية
الناتجة على XY، تُمثل بحاصل الضرب
التنسوري هذا هنا.
ومرة أخرى، يمكننا وضع منخفض على
مصفوفة الوحدة إن كان مفيداً.
إليكم بعض الأمثلة المحددة.
إذا كان X وY عبارة عن qubit و
أجرينا عملية Hadamard على X ولم نفعل شيئاً لـ Y، نحصل على المصفوفة التي ترونها هنا.
إذا من ناحية أخرى، أجرينا عملية Hadamard على Y ولم نفعل شيئاً لـ X، ترتيب حاصل الضرب
التنسوري ينعكس.
وبالتالي نحصل على المصفوفة
التي ترونها هنا.
ليست كل عملية أحادية
على نظام مركب يمكن التعبير عنها كحاصل ضرب تنسوري.
إذا كان لدينا حاصل ضرب تنسوري،
فلدينا استقلال.
وهناك بعض الأمثلة
الأساسية جداً للعمليات التي بالتأكيد
لا تعمل بشكل مستقل على أنظمة متعددة.
على سبيل المثال، إذا كان لـ X وY
نفس مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية، والتي يمكن أن تكون أي
مجموعة حالات كلاسيكية سيجما،
فيمكننا التفكير في عملية
التبديل على الزوج XY.
هذه العملية لا تغير ترتيب النظامين، لا يزال X على
اليسار وY على اليمين، بل تمثل
تبديل محتويات
النظامين. هنا يمكنكم رؤية ذلك معبراً عنه
بصيغة معادلة حيث لدينا حاصل ضرب
تنسوري لحالتين كميتين.
طريقة أخرى لكتابتها هي
كمصفوفة كما نرى هنا.
الطريقة التي يمكنكم التفكير
في هذا الوصف هي أنه يخبركم ما يحدث لمتجهات الأساس القياسي.
وبمجرد أن نعرف ما يحدث
لمتجهات الأساس القياسي، نعرف ما يحدث
لحالات كمية عشوائية بالخطية،
وهو ما ينطبق أيضاً على
هذا التعبير هنا في الواقع.
إذن هذه العملية بالذات هنا تصادف أنها عملية حتمية وكذلك عملية أحادية.
إذا كان X وY عبارة عن qubit، مثلاً، نحصل على هذا التمثيل
المصفوفي هنا.
إليكم ارتباطاً مثيراً للاهتمام
بين عملية التبديل وحالات Bell الأربع، المعروضة هنا
للسهولة.
عملية التبديل تترك
الثلاث الأولى دون تغيير، لكنها تضع إشارة سالبة أمام
حالة Psi minus،
إذن هناك شيء
مميز حول تلك الحالة.
يمكنكم التحقق من هذه المعادلات مباشرة بالنظر إلى هذه المتجهات والنظر فيما يحدث
لحالات الأساس القياسي
تبديل الحالتين الكلاسيكيتين لحالات Bell الثلاث
الأولى لا يفعل شيئاً نحصل على نفس الحالة التي بدأنا بها.
في الحالة الرابعة مع ذلك، الإشارة السالبة تنتقل فعلياً
من حد إلى آخر عندما نجري تبديل الحالات الكلاسيكية،
وهذا يكافئ ضرب المتجه بسالب واحد.
إذن إجراء عملية التبديل بطريقة ما يُخرج إشارة سالبة
من حالة Bell الرابعة هذه.
سيكون لدينا المزيد لنقوله عن
هذه المعادلات لاحقاً، لكن الآن لننتقل إلى
نوع آخر من العمليات، وهو العملية المتحكم بها.
سنفترض أن X عبارة عن qubit وY أي نظام تريدونه.
إذا كانت U عملية أحادية على Y، فإن عملية U المتحكم بها على XY هي العملية المعبر عنها
هنا.
أولاً، باستخدام ترميز ديراك ثم باستخدام ما يسمى
مصفوفة كتلية فقط تخيلوا ملء
هذه المصفوفة الأكبر
بالمصفوفات الأصغر حيث هذه الأصفار تمثل حقاً مصفوفات
مملوءة بأصفار.
إذن كل واحد من هذه الكتل الأربع يمثل مصفوفة لها عدد
من الصفوف والأعمدة يتوافق مع عدد
الحالات الكلاسيكية لـ Y.
فكرة العملية المتحكم بها، التي صادفناها بالفعل
في السياق الكلاسيكي عندما ناقشنا عملية
NOT المتحكم بها،
هي أنه إذا كان X مضبوطاً على صفر،
فلا يحدث شيء لـ Y.
لكن إذا كان X مضبوطاً على واحد،
فإن U تُطبق على Y.
إذن X يسمى qubit التحكم، وY يسمى النظام الهدف، الذي بشكل عام لا
يجب أن يكون qubit.
كمثال محدد،
الذي ذكرته للتو، لدينا عملية NOT المتحكم بها.
إذا كان qubit الأول مضبوطاً
على صفر، لا يحدث شيء. وإذا كان qubit الأول مضبوطاً على واحد، فإن عملية NOT أو ما يكافئها،
عملية سيجما X تُطبق
على qubit الثاني.
وإليكم تمثيلها المصفوفي.
نحن نتحدث عن اثنين من qubit هنا، لذا يمكننا بنفس السهولة
أن نقرر أن qubit الثاني هو التحكم و
الأول هو الهدف.
لوصف تلك العملية، نبدل الترتيب
في حاصل الضرب التنسوري، والنتيجة هي المصفوفة
التي ترونها هنا.
إذا بدلاً من عملية NOT المتحكم بها، نأخذ بعين الاعتبار عملية سيجما
Z المتحكم بها أو عملية Z المتحكم بها.
نحصل على هذا التمثيل
المصفوفي هنا. ولهذه العملية، لا يهم فعلاً
أيهما التحكم وأيهما الهدف.
نحصل على نفس النتيجة في كلتا الحالتين.
يمكننا المضي أبعد والنظر في عملية تبديل متحكم بها.
وهنا نتحدث
عن تبديل اثنين من qubit، لذا ينتهي بنا الأمر بثلاثة من qubit عندما نضمّن qubit التحكم.
التمثيل المصفوفي لكل منها
يبدو هكذا.
إنها عملية مميزة جداً وتُعرف بعملية Fredkin، أو الأكثر شيوعاً gate Fredkin.
عندما نفكر فيها
كـ gate في circuit، سنناقش الـ circuit في الدرس القادم.
المثال الأخير هو عملية NOT
المتحكم بها المتحكم بها، وهي أيضاً
عملية على ثلاثة من qubit.
وإليكم تمثيلها المصفوفي. هذه العملية معروفة أكثر بكثير
باسم عملية Toffoli أو gate Toffoli.
سنناقشها أكثر
وسنرى لماذا هي وعملية Fredkin كلتاهما عمليات مهمة جداً
في درس لاحق.
وهذه نهاية الدرس الثاني. في هذا الدرس، ناقشنا كيف تعمل المعلومات الكمية للأنظمة المتعددة.
آمل أن تنضموا إلي في
الدرس الثالث قريباً، وهو عن circuit
والبروتوكولات والألعاب الكمية.
إلى اللقاء حتى ذلك الحين.